donald trump has targeted muslim
congresswoman elon omar
by tweeting video of the 9 11 attacks
and i wish i could honestly come to you
today and say
this is so sick that donald trump's base
is not going to tolerate it
this is so sick that a majority of
republicans is going to say this is just
too far this has to stop
but that's not true i'd be lying to you
if i told you that this was simply too
far
and that there would be repercussions
for donald trump because there aren't
going to be
friday night donald trump tweeted
footage of the 911 attacks
mixed in with some of illano mars
statements at a banquet for
the council on american islamic
relations last month
along with the phrase we will never
forget
let's look at a little bit of that video
that trump
tweeted uh on friday evening care was
founded after 9 11
because they recognized that some people
did something
so you have no idea right i got another
one another plane just hit
some people did something
oh my goodness there is smoke pouring
out of the pentagon
some people did something
it just flew straight into it
right so this is tantamount to tweeting
video
of terrorist timothy mcveigh to random
catholics
because mcveigh was catholic or was
raised catholic anyway
so here's the the bottom line on this i
i've gotten a lot of requests to comment
on this because i've previously
criticized illanomar trump claims that
this was a critique
of illanomar for her association with
the council on american islamic
relations
there are many very fair criticisms of c
a i r care
they're not a group that i go around
cheerleading the right says
the left is defending sharia law by
defending ilan omar
here uh should the left defend sharia
law no have i ever defended sharia law
no it's just not the issue here okay
tweeting what is effectively a
conspiracy video
associating an individual muslim woman
with 9 9 11 on the basis that she is a
muslim
is disgusting and that's what donald
trump is doing disagreeing with ilanomar
is fine
it's encouraged to state when we
disagree on policy with any of our
elected officials
but sort of hanging islam around her
neck as the reason why she's a problem
is the definition of bigotry and i want
to remind you that no one has been more
disgusting and vile on the topic of 9 11
than donald trump
there's local news footage i don't want
to play it because they're very
aggressive with copyright
but i'll put what trump said uh to upn 9
news right after 9 11 on the screen
trump said 40 wall street
actually was the second tallest building
in downtown manhattan that's his
building
and it was actually before the world
trade center the tallest and then when
they built the world trade center
it became known as the second tallest
and now it's the tallest
trump uh reacting to 9 11 by saying his
building is now the tallest in the
neighborhood again
trump falsely claimed that muslims were
dancing in the streets
of new jersey after 9 11 debunked
trump uh uh uh claimed
that he helped a little bit with
clearing rubble at ground zero
after nine eleven that was a lie trump
claimed to have lost hundreds of friends
in the attacks wasn't able to name
any of them another lie trump promised
to donate ten thousand dollars to the
nine eleven victims which by the way is
like nothing for him
he never actually donated the money but
he took credit for the donation
common thing that he does trump lied and
said he watched people jump from the
windows
on nine eleven saying quote i have a
window in my apartment that was
specifically aimed at the world trade
center
because of the beauty of the whole
downtown manhattan and i watched as
people jumped and i watched the second
plane come in
many people jumped and i witnessed it i
watched that
reportedly trump was miles away at the
time that 911 took place
so this is obscenity at the highest
level and it does not matter
because his base doesn't care pat and
that's why we've been saying if you're
waiting around for trump's base to say
this is it this is to use a phrase pat
likes to use
a bridge too far we're stupid if that's
what we're waiting around for
there's no solution here pat other than
voting in november
yeah i think trump was right when he
said that if he shot someone on fifth
avenue he wouldn't lose any supporters
that turned out to be true uh with these
911 comments he's showing himself to be
a total sociopath making the 911 attacks
about him
and no one really seems to care it's
he's developed a cult of personality
and it's hard to get rid of that he
mimicked the disabled reporter
then denied that that's what he did he
slammed the parents of a military
captain who died in combat
the supposedly pro-military patriotic
republicans just made excuses for trump
he was accused of sexually assaulting
more than a dozen women even
accused of raping a 13 year old with his
buddy jeffrey epstein
and it just didn't matter so it's no
shock whatsoever
that zero republican members of congress
have raised objections
about what donald trump did on friday
with this video and with ilana mar
and the only solution is to remove the
guy in november of 2020
make sure you're following the david
pakman show on instagram
at david pakman show and while you're
there follow me
at david.pakman one of today's sponsors
is privacy.com pacman this is a free
service that i've actually been using
myself for a while now and i love it
you just take a few seconds to link your
debit card
or bank account to privacy.com's mobile
app or browser extension for firefox and
chrome
and what that does is allow you to
instantly create virtual credit cards
that are linked to your bank account so
that you're not actually putting
your real debit card number on
the internet and you use these virtual
credit card numbers to buy things online
and with one click of a button
you have the ability to create multiple
virtual cards delete cards freeze and
unfreeze cards you can put a limit on a
card
so a company won't be able to charge you
more than you actually want them to
and it protects you from being hacked it
protects you
from companies being hacked which we've
been talking about for a while on the
program
and it's perfect for signing up for free
trial
somewhere if you don't want your real
credit card number
to be exposed and on file and their app
and browser extension
let you autofill the virtual credit card
number into the credit card field
when you're buying things online there
are a ton of different advantages to
shopping and
paying bills with a system like this
everything is totally secure
and encrypted and in some situations you
can earn
five percent cash back on your purchases
it's all completely free all you have to
do is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
everybody in our audience who signs up
gets
five dollars towards your first purchase
when you sign up using that link below